all right so I joked that this would
happen last week on Twitter and it's
happening Donald Trump now has said that
he does not know if Rudy Giuliani is his
lawyer of course Rudy Giuliani now under
criminal federal investigation two of
Rudy Giuliani's associates have been
arrested trying to leave the country on
one-way plane tickets I tweeted last
week after Olivia Newton si wrote that
Trump says he hasn't spoken to Rudy but
Rudy tells me he spoke to Trump
yesterday Trump says he doesn't know if
Rudy is his attorney
Rudy tells me he is and he has no reason
to think he's not I tweeted Rudy who is
coming in 3 2 1 now we're not yet at
Donald Trump saying Rudy Giuliani yeah I
don't really know who that is but we are
at Rudy my attorney oh I don't know
about that here's video Donald Trump
asked is Rudy Giuliani your lawyer
check out Donald Trump's answer well I
don't know I haven't spoken to Rudy I
spoke to him yesterday briefly
he's a very good attorney and he has
been my attorney I haven't spoken to him
I spoke to him yesterday well so you
have spoken to him I guess you mean you
haven't spoken to him in the last few
hours but you spoke to him yesterday
he's a good attorney I don't know if
he's my attorney Rudy Giuliani was asked
are you still Donald Trump's attorney
and he said that he is at least at the
most recent time I am still his lawyer
until he tells me I'm not I spoke to him
yesterday and I have no reason to
believe I'm not he said to New York
magazines Olivia Newton
Rudy was also asked whether he thinks
Trump is going to throw him under the
bus and he said he doesn't think so
which does not it's like when Trump says
he is full confidence in you and 24
hours later you've been forced to resign
this is exactly what Trump did when
Michael Cohen who's now in prison when
Michael Cohen his former personal
attorney was starting to get into
trouble Michael Cohen oh I don't know he
was my attorney at one point he's not
the best guy and you know he was asking
me for all this stuff that I didn't give
him Trump after that video though that I
played
tweet nice things about Rudy but this is
the start of the distancing from Rudy
Guiliani we've seen it done before
and Trump is doing it again coffee boy
Rudy Guiliani he was barely involved
with anything I did when you start
ghosting your lawyer your prominent
famous on TV every day lawyer because
he's under criminal investigation and
two of his associates have been arrested
and charged that's not good and there's
an important thing to understand here
and this may become relevant actually
depending on where impeachment goes
depending on where the criminal
investigation into Rudy Giuliani goes
what's important to understand is that
as his personal attorney it's not clear
that Rudy Giuliani is doing legal work
per se for Trump in the sense that Rudy
is a lawyer and calling him Trump's
lawyer is useful for attorney-client
privilege but in the strictest sense
other lawyers are doing Trump's actual
legal work the filings and the work you
would typically associate with an
attorney Rudy Giuliani is basically
doing influence-peddling meetings all
over the world and television
appearances but the bulk of the legal
work is not being done by really Rudy
Rudy Giuliani if any at all it's
becoming a bad comedy does anybody
believe that someone in Donald Trump's
position possibly facing charges of all
kinds facing impeachment doesn't know
who his lawyer is that doesn't seem like
something that is very reasonable even
considering that this is Donald Trump
bizarre times that we are living in and
who knows if a week from now Rudy
Giuliani will be under indictment it's
anyone's guess this may be the last we
hear of the Rudy investigation or the
guy may be indicted next week either
would be equally surprising or
unsurprising to me at this point in time
let me know what you think Rudy's future
is legally and also when it comes to his
role with Donald Trump today's program
brought to you in part by Blink accom
slash Pakman blinka is a great service
that i use all the time what they do is
they take
thousands of the most popular
non-fiction books including the newest
bestsellers they condense them into
15-minute audiobooks that you can listen
to and you still get the most crucial
information and insights from each book
and I've listened to a ton of books on
blink Asst I recently checked out
soccer na mcc's by Simon Cooper we do
have after all the World Cup going on
recently we also have been talking about
BS jobs and there is a great new book of
BS jobs by David Graeber which I
listened to on bling cos they're
constantly adding new books to the
platform you will never run out of
fascinating and critically acclaimed
books to enjoy and our audience can get
a seven day free trial by going to blink
accom slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube I'm putting a link in the video
description and after the free trial if
you like it you can continue enjoying
thousands of condensed audiobooks for
about 5 bucks a month that's be Li NK is
t.com /pa que mas